I think of really cute round animals and
like soy sauce okay
the coins that the elf hat and Pokemon
Wow like the wine is a one owner third
race top it smells fried mmm that's good
fry this wish I was not expecting now I
like that
that's like sweet and savory the same
time it's like a spicy rice cracker I've
Eve ever I'd pop cereal it's just a big
box yeah this kind of just seems like an
airplane snack yeah like this is like
their version of like the two passively
I've had these before and I love him I
like the name already you can eat the
inner wrapper which is a lot of fun
why are you supposed to eat paper
understand do big just suck on ya huh
this is a really good way to shut up
your kids because you feed them this
there's no way they can have a
conversation and I think this is what my
mom was doing well it's like very chewy
No No oh this looks like twigs those are
a little fish what see the eyes right
that looks like sardines oh my god oh
well it could be an eel that was damn
good it's like salty mmm not bad it
tastes like a fish tank smells like Jim
and he tastes good together this is so
surprising you don't want to eat these
before a date though
oh my god here's something I can get on
board with she looks so happy when you
turn to ten also a piggy bank could you
just see a little like chubby baby like
carrying this around no just scary get
into my candy what child with man
strength can do this delicious then I
come to my desk and just see these
everywhere I had an episode what the
[ __ ] does the pig have to do with yellow
snacks
they're both simply delicious
yeah I actually liked everything the
crackers were a dark horse I really
enjoyed the very understated looks very
delicious there were some weird
combinations going on like yeah fish and
almonds on site I was like no but taste
yes I feel like it's got to be a really
fun place to eat yeah cuz like there's
some crazy like not just like the
combinations but the presentation of
some of this was pretty extraordinary